salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
aujourd'hui on va avoir besoin de ça et
ce n'est pas pour vous parler de petites
bestioles mais de géographie des cinq
plus petit pays du monde ils sont
minuscules mais malgré leur taille vous
allez le voir on ne peut pas les louper
on commence ce classement par le
cinquième plus petit pays du monde il
s'agit de
Samarin à ne pas confondre avec
Saint-Martin une île des Antilles ça
marin donc ou sans Marino est un
micro-état indépendant enclavé dans la
botte italienne au nord dans la chaîne
des apenins pas très loin de la mer
Adriatique quand je vous dis que c'est
petit ce n'est pas une vue de l'esprit
cet état s'étend sur 61,2 km² pour vous
donner une idée il est à peine plus
grand que la ville de Montpellier est un
peu plus petit que celle de Nantes sa
marin est dominé par le mont Titan sur
lequel se dresse trois tours qui ont
fait la réputation du site elles
assuraient autrefois sa défense selon la
légende ce petit pays doit son nom à un
tailleur de pierre chrétien appelé marin
en l'an 301 fuyant les persécutions de
l'empereur turclésien il s'installe sur
le mont Titan très vite d'autres
chrétiens le rejoignent et font ici une
communauté religieuse Saint-Marin est
surtout connu pour être l'une des plus
anciennes République du monde elle a été
proclamée dès le 13ème siècle et son
système constitutionnel actuel d'attrait
de l'année 1600 aujourd'hui le micro est
à compte une population d'appennes 34000
personnes c'est l'équivalent de la ville
d'Auxerre et jusqu'à la crise financière
de 2008 c'était l'un des pays les plus
riches au monde par habitant direction
maintenant le Pacifique Sud à l'Est de
l'Australie pour découvrir notre
quatrième plus petit pays du monde allez
il faut zoomer sur la carte encore un
peu
un petit peu plus et voici tout va bien
il s'agit d'un archipel composé de 9
atolls au total ces îles coralliennes
s'étendent sur seulement 26 km². à titre
de comparaison c'est la superficie d'une
ville comme Orléans chacune à son petit
nom en tout valuant la langue locale
polynésienne et comme j'aime les défis
je vais essayer de toutes vous les citer
alors il y a nanuma nanoumaga
la capitale
fiou ancien territoire colonisé par les
Britanniques tout Valou accède à son
indépendance en 1978 mais il se
maintient dans le Commonwealth
formellement son chef d'État reste donc
la reine Elizabeth II loin de la plus
londonienne tout Valou est un petit
paradis terrestre avec des plages de
sable blanc des eaux turquoises et une
végétation luxuriante malheureusement
l'archipel est menacé par la montée des
eaux dû au réchauffement climatique
selon les scientifiques depuis 1993 le
niveau de l'océan à tout-value Monte de
plus de 5 mm tous les ans c'est plus
rapide que la moyenne mondiale qui
s'établit à 3,5 mm par an cette montée
des eaux accélère
des côtes et menacent de faire
disparaître totalement ce petit pays
allez on prend nos paillettes et on rame
en direction du troisième plus petit
pays du monde Nao bon d'accord j'exagère
un peu naouru est situé à 1400 km de
tout-value dans l'hémisphère sud juste
en dessous de l'équateur d'ailleurs son
drapeau coupé en deux par une ligne
transversale sous laquelle se trouve une
étoile illustre très bien cette
situation géographique au fil des ans la
vie de ses habitants a été influencée
par les différentes présences étrangères
sur l'île colonisés par les Britanniques
en 1798 Nao où est ensuite passé aux
mains des Allemands à la fin du 19e
siècle ces derniers y découvrent
d'énormes gisements de phosphate une
substance minérale utilisée comme
fertilisant et qui entre aussi dans la
fabrication des exposés après un passage
sous le contrôle de l'Australie naouru
accède enfin à son indépendance
en 1968 grâce à l'extraction du
phosphate les NAO Rouen s'enrichissent
et accepte un niveau de vie élevé dans
les années 70 très élevé même pour
certains ils devient le pays possédant
le plus haut pays par habitant du monde
3 fois plus élevé que celui d'un
habitant des États-Unis à l'époque mais
ça ne dure pas dans les années 1990 les
gisements de phosphate s'épuisent et
l'économie de l'île s'effondre
aujourd'hui le taux de chômage du pays
atteint 90% de sa population active
l'abondance a également eu des effets
pervers sur la santé de la population
naourou est en effet connu pour avoir le
taux d'obésité le plus élevé au monde
61% des adultes sont affectés autrefois
petit paradis naturel Nao est devenu
l'un des pays les moins visités au monde
revenons sous nos latitudes pour une
visite du deuxième plus petit État du
monde
top je suis un rocher situé sur la Côte
d'Azur je suis une principauté connue
pour mes casinos et mon Grand Prix de
Formule 1 je suis je suis vous l'avez
deviné Monaco
ville état situé en bord de Méditerranée
la Principauté s'étend sur une
superficie de
2,02 km². c'est moins que Central Park à
New York forteresse stratégique au
Moyen-Âge le territoire était à
l'origine aux mains de la République de
Gênes en 1297 Monaco devient la
propriété du génois François Grimaldi
c'est le début de la longue lignée de
prince qui se succéderont jusqu'à Albert
II sans jamais être roi et si Monaco
n'est pas un royaume c'est aussi un peu
en raison de sa taille tout petit État
le Rocher a besoin que ses voisins
acceptent son statut si particulier la
Principauté a d'ailleurs signé en 1918
un traité avec la France qui lui accorde
une forme de protection et ceci à
certaines en particulier si la dynastie
des Grimaldi venait à s'éteindre le
territoire monégasque intégrerait la
France Monaco bat tous les records c'est
le pays le plus densément peuplé au
monde avec une population de plus de
39000 résidents le rocher conte environ
19000 habitants au kilomètre carré à
titre de comparaison en France on est en
moyenne à 119 habitants par kilomètre
carré Monaco est aussi l'état qui compte
la plus grande proportion de
millionnaires et de milliardaires bref
le rocher est une sorte de pierre
précieuse pour terminer cette vidéo on
reste en Europe un peu plus au sud
retour en Italie le plus petit État du
monde est enclavé dans la ville de Rome
le Vatic 44 hectares c'est grosso modo
20 fois plus petit que le domaine du
château de Versailles le siège de
l'Église catholique est devenu
indépendant le 11 février 1929 c'est le
seul État au monde ou l'une des langues
officielles est le latin on y parle
aussi l'italien l'allemand et le
français pour la diplomatie d'ailleurs
pour les organisations internationales
la résidence du pape est officiellement
un état francophone il faut que je fasse
attention à ce que je dis en fait
environ la moitié de la population du
Saint Siège vit en dehors de la Cité du
Vatican
occupant des fonctions diplomatiques
dans le monde entier en tout le Vatican
compte à peine plus de 800 citoyens
faisant aussi de lui le pays le moins
peuplé du monde que d'habitants mais qui
savent vivre le Vatican et le pays où
l'on consomme le plus de 20 par habitant
74 litres par an et par personne soit 99
bouteilles et pas que du vin de Metz on
en a d'ailleurs fait un poste sur notre
compte Instagram n'hésitez pas à le
consulter revenons à nos moutons les
habitants du Vatican sont pour la
plupart des ecclésiastiques et des
il y en a 135 chargée de la sécurité du
pape ses gardes constituent d’ailleurs
l’une des plus petites et des plus
anciennes armées du monde décidément
mais ne vous fiez pas cette litanie de
petits chiffres associés au Vatican
c'est un pays très riche la cité-État
abrite la basilique Saint-Pierre la plus
grande église au monde ainsi que
certaines des œuvres d'art les plus
célèbres de la Renaissance comme la
Pieta une statue en marbre de
Michel-Ange et la création d'Adam qu'il
a peint sur le plafond de la chapelle
Sixtine évidemment ça fait lever les
yeux au ciel et voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout c'est le meilleur
soutien que vous pouvez apporter à la
chaîne j'espère d'ailleurs que vous
l'avez apprécié n'hésitez pas à mettre
un pouce bleu en l'air et à me proposer
des sujets pour les prochaines vidéos et
si ce n'est pas déjà fait abonnez-vous
comme ça je pourrais peut-être fonder un
nouveau royaume le jamiland
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]